- Oh, no.
I'm just going to spit on the
table, cause I don't care.
I don't care; my mouth
hurts too much to stop.
(bouncy music)
- [Voiceover] Bacon flavored vodka.
- It smells like bacon dog treats.
- Yeah.
- Whoa.
- Owwww.
- I hate vodka so much.
- Why?
- Because it's terrible.
- I love vodka.
- You love Russian accents.
- I'm salivating like
crazy, like look at that.
Look at this. Look.
- No.
- My mouth is just fighting
it. It's like no, no.
- [Voiceover] Yogurt liquor.
- [Voiceover] Yogurt!
- Like a bowling pin that has milk in it.
- Since 1575?
This is older than America.
- Who ever thought that like yogurt
and liquor sounds appealing, though?
- Oh my God.
It tastes like cheese that went bad.
- I like it.
- That's yummy.
- That is very good.
- But it's like kind of what I imagine
the consistency of semen would be.
- I've never seen Gabby this upset.
- I'm horrified.
- Except when
someone says women can't do something.
- [Voiceover] Scorpion Mezcal
- (screams)
- Whoa.
- There is a scorpion in it.
- You get distracted by the fun hat,
and you don't even notice there's
a dead bug in it.
- Excellent.
- If I had to be killed and
put into some sort of bottle,
I would not be opposed to tequila.
- I'd want to be put in ice cream.
- I feel like he's actually alive,
and he's going to be
like "Gotcha Bitches!"
- [Voiceover] Chilli Vodka
- [Voiceover] Naga Chilli Vodka
- Like the Ark of the
Covenant in liquid form,
it will melt your face off.
- Any time there's skulls on something,
it means poison or danger or don't.
(yelling)
- That's exactly what-
- It's on fire.
- Oh my God!
- Oh, my God. Oh, my God. Oh, my God.
- Yeah, this is the worst idea.
- Oh, my stomach hates it.
- Allison's sweating and crying
and her face is red.
- This would probably, like, melt a key,
like if you dip a key
in this (bleep), right?
Just like-
- There's a Shakespeare play,
where there's a character
who gets his tongue cut off.
I envy that character.
- That's the beauty of the
international community.
- Lotta ways to get real weird.
(bouncy music)
- (burps) Oh, even my
burp tastes like fire.